IAN LEWIS: So this is the
"Making Sense with IoT--"
"Making Sense of IoT
Data with the Cloud."
So if you're wrong room, then
you can kind of check out now.
So my name's Ian Lewis.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
I'm based in Tokyo, Japan.
So if you're ever out there, you
can kind of give me a holler.
I'm kind of into Python
and Go and IoT and cloud
and those type of things.
So if you're ever
interested, you
can kind of hit me up
on Twitter @IanMLewis.
I'm always on there and I'm
really willing to talk to you.
And I'd love to hear
from you about questions
or things like that if you think
of them later after the talk.
So today we're going to
be talking about IoT.
And so IoT is the Internet
of Things, obviously.
And that enables you to get a
lot more data about the world
around you and to be able to
use that data to make better
decisions about how to
do things, improve things
in your life, be more
efficient, et cetera.
So anything from
smartphones to dishwashers
to just connected devices
that can measure sensor data
like temperature or humidity
or those type of things.
And all of those are kind of
creating all of this data.
But dealing with that data
can actually pretty hard.
You want to actually be
able to use that data later.
So let's say that you
have a great idea for kind
of a connected device.
Maybe it's a robot arm.
Maybe it's a sensor.
Maybe it's a dishwasher.
So once you have this
data or this new idea
and it's collecting all this
data, there's a lot of things
that you have to
kind of think about.
You have to think about
being able to connect
the device to the network
to be able to send the data.
So establishing the
connections, being
able to do authentication, being
able to manage that connection
so that it stays live so
you can actually send data.
Then you have to be
able to actually read
the data from the sensors.
You have to know enough
about the hardware
to be able to read the
data from the sensor,
to be able to then
take it in your program
and actually be able to send it.
Then you have to actually send
the data over the network.
And this can be done
in a number of ways.
But what if your connection
is over a wireless connection?
Maybe it kind of
goes in and out.
You have to be able to deal with
those type of connection issues
that they might arise.
A lot of IoT related
devices are on SIM networks
or on 3G or that type of thing.
You have to then be
able to take that data
and process it on the server.
So you have to be able to figure
out how to take that data,
do some processing with it,
and then actually store it.
But you can imagine
that if there's
lots and lots of devices
and lots of data coming in,
you have to be able to handle
all of that data coming in.
And then you have to be able
to actually store the data.
So perhaps you
have a large number
of devices that are
all generating data.
You have to be able to
store a large amount of data
and be able to handle
that type of throughput.
And then there's one
last thing that I
think is like a fairly--
that people kind of overlook.
Like you can actually get
the data and store it,
but then you have to be
able to get the data out
easily and analyze
it and figure out
how to make the decisions
smarter and be more efficient.
So this analysis part is
actually also really, really
important, being able to
get the data out actually
once you've stored it.
So in this talk, I
kind of want to go
through how you would actually
build an IoT application that
is creating a lot of data and
needs to process that data
and store that
data in the cloud.
And so I'm going to
kind of go through kind
of a high level, what this type
of project would look like,
what are the typical
type of things
you would see in
an IoT application.
And then eventually we'll
kind of get down and actually
start with a particular
use case or a case study
about how to actually
architect an application.
So some of the
typical components
in an IoT
application-- so here's
an eye level architecture.
You might have a
bunch of devices.
Say this is like an
industrial application.
I'm thinking mostly about
industrial applications.
A lot of people
kind of think of IoT
as kind of this connected
home type of thing.
And that's also relevant.
But I kind of think
of connected home
as a special type of
industrial use cases.
So I'm going to speak in a
very generic way about how
to do IoT applications.
But here's kind of a
typical architecture.
You might have a bunch of
devices like in your home
or in a factory or at a power
generation plant or whatever.
And they're all
collecting data and then
sending that data to a cloud
service that can actually then
process and store that data.
And you might have the
devices actually connected
via just a cable to something
like a gateway server that
will actually send the data
over the network, or maybe
over a short wave
wireless so that it
works on a short distance.
But then from the
gateway you can actually
send to the internet.
So you may have a number of
different types of setups.
Or the device itself could
be connected directly
to the internet.
In that sense, it would kind
of serve as its own gateway.
So you can have a number
of different scenarios.
But as a general
rule, you just kind of
have this gateway type of
thing in your architecture
quite often.
And then when you kind of
zoom in under the cloud side,
you might actually have a
number of moving parts there.
So you might have a front end
that actually takes in the data
from your device,
and then some back
ends that actually process
and store the data.
So there might be
any number of type
of permutations of this type of
background-- or this back end.
But you might see these type
of-- but all architectures will
tend to fall in this
type of diagram.
So now that I've
looked at that, I'll
try to go in and fill the blanks
about what you might actually
use for the front and the
back end for your application
in a kind of a case study later.
But next I want to talk about
the actual types of data
that you would have to
send between devices
and your service.
So we've thought
a lot about this,
and one of the types of
data that you would send
or that you would
have is metadata.
So these are device
IDs or classes
or models or revisions,
those type of things,
about your device.
And so this would
be basically data
that exists but doesn't
really change very much.
This is something that's very
static for a particular device.
And so it might
give you information
about the capabilities
of the device.
But it doesn't really change.
And it could be kind
of freeform data.
You don't really
necessarily know
exactly what might be in here.
Depending on the type of
device, it might be different.
Also state data.
State data is very
similar to metadata
except that this will kind
of change fairly often,
because the device itself might
change state or change location
or whatever.
So here we might have
the status of the device,
whether it's ready or its in
an error state or it's failing.
You might have
the status of each
and every one of the
devices or the sensors.
So in this case
we have one that's
like a temperature sensor that
shows the current temperature
and says that it's reading.
And we might also have location,
if, say, your device has
a GPS or something like that.
So this might be
updated every minute
or every hour or whatever.
But it's kind of continually
updated as the state
changes for your device.
Next is telemetry data.
So telemetry is not really
a commonly used word,
but it's generally
time series data.
So this is the data that
the kind of meat and bones--
or meat and potatoes
type of application data
that your sensors
are generating.
So basically over time, it'll
generate read only data that
can be viewed as a time series.
So maybe the humidity in the
room or the amount of water
flowing through a pipe
or something like that.
And then it's
basically read only.
So it doesn't update.
But depending on the number
of devices that you have,
you could very quickly get
into very large amounts of data
and a very high throughput.
So you need to be
able to handle that.
And generally you
quickly have to apply
big data type of strategies.
The fourth type of data
that I wanted to talk about
was commands.
So commands are things
that would actually
be sent to the device, so
telling a specific device
to spin 360 degrees or spin
90 degrees, or something
like that, or run a self
cleaning cycle or do something.
And these are
generally not really--
they have a specific
type of properties
in that they are not really
represented in state data
very easily.
So when you send a
command to a device,
you want to actually have
that command execute one time,
and you want to be able to
know if the device actually
succeeded in running
the command or not.
So things like
sending the command
and having it actually run twice
because of intermittent type
of communication
problems or things
like that, like if you
told it to turn 90 degrees,
if it actually ran it twice,
it would turn 180 degrees.
And you don't really
want it to do that.
So you want these
kind of like run
only once type of semantics.
It's also kind of
temporal, so you
want to have some sort
of TTL or something
in order to be able to time
out these type of commands.
So that's some of
the types of data
and general view of architecture
for a [? NC ?] application.
So next I want to talk about
actually applying those ideas
or applying the cloud to
solve some of those problems.
And so I'm going to do
kind of a case study
and take those set
of requirements,
and then actually try to create
an architecture that will
satisfy those requirements.
So the requirements for this
particular application that I'm
going to do are pretty simple.
It's just basically read
some temperature data
from a large number of
devices for analysis later.
And then we're going
to manage the info
and status of each device.
So if we read
these requirements,
we can kind of see that the
types of data that I was
talking about kind of pop out.
So here we have the
temperature data
would be our telemetry data.
This is the data that
runs as a time series.
And then info about
each device is metadata.
And then the status
of each device
could be seen as state, right?
So let's go and actually
start trying to architect
an application like this.
So our architecture is
going to be pretty simple.
I'm not going to use a gateway.
Our device will actually connect
directly to the internet.
So in that sense, it's
acting as its own gateway.
And so when you look at
the overall architecture,
it looks very simple.
But if you actually drill in,
it can be a little bit more
complicated.
So there's a number of
things that you kind of
have to think about.
So on the device
side, you actually
have to think about which
device you're going to use,
like how you're going to
actually build the device,
what sort of
sensors you're going
to have on the device, as
well as the software that's
going to run on the device.
So you have to be able to
actually run the software
or create the software that's
going to run on the device.
What kind of software
is that going to be?
Then you also on
the cloud side need
to be able to
handle things like,
say you're pretty telemetry
data and you're continuously
sending that to the cloud.
What if the wireless
is kind of flaky?
How do you handle
that sort of thing?
Also, how do you handle
the stream processing?
Like if the device
sends data to the cloud
and the cloud's not ready
to actually process it,
how do you deal with that?
So we're going to
actually deal with that
by using a message queue.
So a message queue is going to
take a message from our device.
In this case it's going to
be telling us the temperature
data in a message.
And that's going to
get stored in the queue
until the stream
processing system is ready.
And then the string
processing system
is going to take that data
from the message queue,
and then write that to
our time series database.
And then we're going to store
our state data and metadata
in a state database.
So I'm going to go through
all of these and actually kind
of fill in what each one of
these are as we go along here.
So the first thing
I want to talk about
is the actual device.
So for my little
application, I'm
going to be using a BeagleBone.
And so that's this device over
here, if I can switch over.
So I have a little
device over here.
This is a BeagleBone with some
temperature sensors on it.
I'll show you that
a little bit later.
So going back, the BeagleBone
is an open source mini computer
that runs Linux.
It's very similar to
kind of a Raspberry Pi
if you're familiar with that.
It's developed by Seed Studio.
Or this particular one is
developed by Seed Studio.
It's an open source one,
so if you wanted to,
you could print these circuits
out yourself if you wanted to.
But it comes with these really
cool connectors, these I2C
and RS-232 connectors, which
make it easy to kind of plug
into devices without actually
having to solder them.
And Seed Studio also makes
some cool Grove sensors,
which you can actually
plug into the BeagleBone.
and then actually get
it to connect and work
without actually
having to solder it,
which is pretty cool for
doing some prototyping.
So here I'm going to use this
analog to digital converter
and a temperature sensor.
So the temperature sensor
creates some analog data,
and then that's going
to get converted
to digital to actually go to the
Grove-- or to the BeagleBone,
sorry.
The next thing I want to
talk about is the software.
So on the BeagleBone,
it runs Linux.
And so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to create an
application on Node.js.
And there's this
really cool library
called the Johnny Five, which
is a JavaScript robotics and IoT
platform.
And it's got a really cool logo.
And yeah, I picked
it for the logo.
But it's got a really
cool interface.
And it's written in JavaScript.
And most people kind
of know JavaScript.
And JavaScript is a heck of a
lot better than writing C++.
So that's what I chose.
So Johnny Five, like if you
actually write an application,
it kind of looks like this.
It's just regular JavaScript.
So you can just require
the Johnny Five module.
And then I'm also using
the BeagleBone I/O module,
which is used to connect to the
interfaces on the BeagleBone.
And then you can kind of
pass the BeagleBone objects
to Johnny Five to
create a board object.
And then you can set an on
ready signal or a function
so that when the board is ready
you can actually run some code.
So you'll set up the board.
And then it will set up all
of the connectors and things
like that on the board.
And so when it's ready, then you
can actually run the function.
So that's really
good so that you
don't have to deal
with timing and things
like that for when
you're actually
running your application.
So the next thing
that I'm going to do
is I'm going to store
the state database state
data in Firebase.
So you might have heard about
Firebase from the keynote.
Firebase is a
platform for creating
mobile applications or
real time applications,
especially mobile.
But what's really
cool about it is it
includes this NoSQL back end,
which is kind of JSON based.
So it looks really a
lot like a JSON object
and works like a JSON object.
So it has kind of a tree
structure inside of it.
And so I'm going to be
using this to actually store
the state database
or state data.
So as the application
is running,
it will update the state data.
So Firebase, you can kind
of connect to it like this.
You require the Firebase module.
And then you can
authenticate to it using
the Firebase token generator.
And then once you've
authenticated,
you'll have a reference
to the database.
And then you can use that to
set objects to the database.
And right now I'm just
setting a whole JSON object
to a particular key
in the database.
And this is just going to
contain all of my sensor
or my state data for the device.
And so as I'm kind of looping
through the application,
as it's reading data
from the device,
it'll actually update
the state as well.
So for the back end part,
for the telemetry data,
I'm going to be
using Cloud Pub/Sub.
So this is our messaging
queue that we're
going to use to take
the telemetry data.
We're then going to process
that data using Dataflow.
And then we're going to
store the time series
data in Cloud Bigtable.
So I'll talk about each
one of these in turn.
But what's really great
is that each one of these
will scale to handle
a large amount of data
coming into them.
So each of these
independently scale,
which will allow me to
handle many, many devices
in the future.
So Cloud Pub/Sub is just our
managed fully time messaging
service.
So it basically just acts
as a messaging queue.
So you can put data
into the queue.
And then on the outside
of it, the Dataflow
will actually take
messages from the queue
and then process
them as it's ready.
So this will do a
lot to help kind
of smooth out sending data from
the device to the processing
system back end.
And Dataflow is kind of a
unified programming model
and managed service for
doing streaming data.
So this is very similar to
something like Spark or Hadoop.
Or it's kind of like an
in-between between them.
But it's unified so that it
works with streaming or batch
models.
So in this case we're going
to use it for streaming,
but you can also
use it for batch.
Basically what you
do is you create
kind of a pipeline with a
bunch of different steps.
And each one of those
steps you define how
to handle one piece of data.
And then it kind of handles
how to scale that up
and parallelize that for you.
So we'll look at that
a little bit later.
And then lastly Cloud
Bigtable is a NoSQL database
that Google uses
internally for a lot
of our core services
like Search and Analytics
and Maps and Gmail.
Essentially what it is a
key-value type of database,
but the keys are kind of sorted
kind of lexicographically.
So that's great for things
like time series data.
It also maps from one
key to a row of data.
So you can have multiple values.
So each of those
are in a column.
So what we can do is
you'll have a key,
and then you could
map to any number
of pieces of sensor data.
In our case, we're just
going using temperature data.
But you could imagine that you
could have many different types
of sensor data.
So on the application side,
in order to send to Pub/Sub,
we're going to create
our thermometer object.
This is a Johnny
Five object which
will read data from the Grove
sensor every five seconds.
And then basically we'll set a
callback on this thermometer.
So when there's data available,
it'll run this function.
And we'll just publish
that data to Cloud Pub/Sub.
So here I'm sending the
data with our device
ID and a channel and a timestamp
and the actual temperature
data.
So this just goes into Cloud
Pub/Sub as a JSON data.
And then on the
Dataflow side, here we
have a couple of things
to just set up Dataflow
be able to read from Pub/Sub
and write to Cloud Bigtable.
So these are just
basically objects that I'm
going to create from
some command line
arguments to tell Dataflow what
Pub/Sub topic I should use,
what Bigtable
table I should use,
and what Bigtable
cluster I should use.
And then we'll actually
create a Dataflow pipeline.
So this pipeline is just,
you create an object.
This is Java code.
So we just create a
pipeline from our objects
or from our options.
And then we're going to
create a three part pipeline.
One is just a built in step
that we can use for Dataflow.
This is Pub/Sub, or
to read from Pub/Sub.
And then we're going to read
that using a JSON coder, which
is allows us to reach JSON data.
And then we're going to apply
this mutation transform,
which is a transform that
I wrote in Java code.
And then at the end
we're going to write
to a particular table in
Bigtable based on the options
that we had.
So here's how I'm going to write
my actual mutation transform.
So I can write code
for Cloud Dataflow that
will define how to
process each record that
comes in to Dataflow.
So we're going to be
reading from Pub/Sub.
So each message that
comes into Pub/Sub
is going to be passed
to my transform.
And then this process
element is going
to be called in order to
actually process that.
So going through that,
we're reading from the JSON
object that was passed in.
So we're reading a
single JSON object
and all of the fields--
device ID, channel, timestamp,
and data.
And then we're going
to create a rowKey
for Cloud Bigtable using our
device ID and the timestamp.
And then we're going to create a
PUT request for Cloud Bigtable.
And so now I'm
just going to loop
through the keys that
were sent in the data.
And in this case, it's
just the temperature data.
But we're going to just
add that column to our row,
and then finally
send the PUT request
as output for our transform.
So that's going to basically
just change our JSON object
into a PUT request
for Cloud Bigtable.
So now that I talked a
little bit about that,
I'm going to jump over
to actually show you
a working example of that.
Let's see.
So first, I want to
start my application.
So here, I'm on my BeagleBone.
And I'm going to
start my Node.js app.
This takes a second to start up.
But once that
starts up, we should
be able to go into Firebase.
I have my Firebase-- this is
actually the old console here.
So once that actually
starts up, we
should be able to see
that the state data starts
getting updated into Firebase.
And you can kind of see from the
management console in Firebase
which fields are
actually getting updated.
So here we can see that
the status of this sensor
is pending.
So once that gets starting, we
can see that it's now reading.
And the temperature currently
is a nice 20 degrees Celsius.
And I have this set up to
read every five seconds.
So this timestamp will
get updated as well as
the temperature.
So now that I've got that,
I'm going to go ahead--
this is actually reading data
and sending it to Pub/Sub.
So Pub/Sub is kind of
queuing up that data.
And then I can actually
start my Dataflow pipeline.
So Dataflow, basically
in order to start it,
you just write it like
a regular Java program.
So here I'm just going to
use Maven to start it up.
But there's also
an Eclipse plug-in
that you can use to run Dataflow
jobs directly from Eclipse.
So if you're an Eclipse
person, then that's
definitely something
you should look into.
But I'm kind of a
command line junkie,
so I like to use
the command line.
So if you run this, this will
actually start up Dataflow,
and Dataflow will
actually start up some VMs
on GCE, or on Compute Engine,
in order to actually run
your processing.
And that will kind
of scale up and down
based on the number of
messages coming into Pub/Sub.
But it takes a few minutes
to actually start those VMs.
So I actually have
one running here.
That's the cooking show
way of doing things.
So I've got one
already running here.
Let's go and look at Dataflow.
So if you go into the cloud
console and you go to big data
in to Dataflow, once
you've created a job,
you can see it in the
list of jobs in Dataflow.
And then if you
click on that job,
you can actually see a
visualization of the steps
within that job.
So here, these are
the three steps
that I created in
my Java program.
So here it shows
the Pub/Sub read.
This is the Java
transform that I wrote.
And then this is the part to
actually write to Bigtable.
So you could have any
number of permutations
of how you actually create
a Dataflow pipeline.
But I just kind of
created a simple one here.
And it doesn't have to
be linear like this.
You can actually have,
from my transform,
I could actually have a step two
after it to write to Bigtable,
but also write
to, say, BigQuery.
So BigQuery is another
kind of analytical database
that you could use to
store data, and then
run SQL queries over it.
So you could definitely
do things like that.
That's kind of one of the
really great and flexible things
about Dataflow.
So just going back, and
then I have a little sort
of visualization of the data.
So if I go over here--
so this is a little app
that kind of will query
Bigtable in real time
to actually check to see
the temperature currently.
So this is pretty boring.
It's just basically
saying the same.
But if we go over
here and we kind of
squeeze this with my
finger, hopefully it
should actually make the
temperature increase here.
So I'm pretty hot today
I guess, 25 degrees.
So you can kind of do these
sort of real time applications
as well.
So this is actually--
we'll show you
kind of that the
data is actually
going all the way through
the whole pipeline
and actually ending up in
Bigtable, because we're
actually doing a Bigtable
scan here to get the data.
So I'm going to jump
back to the slides.
So kind of just to
wrap up, I wanted
to go through and
make sure that we
checked all the boxes
for our requirements
for our application.
So we were able to
read the temperature
data from the device.
We were able to handle a
large number of devices,
because each of the back end
pieces-- Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
and Bigtable-- are only
able to scale and handle
large number of devices.
We're also able to
pull out and analyze
that data using Bigtable.
We can do that either
by scanning Bigtable,
or we can develop, like
I said, other methods
like writing
directly to BigQuery
and then doing SQL queries on
it and doing analysis that way.
And then we were also able
to manage the info and status
of each device using Firebase.
So these are a number of how
you could kind of put together
different parts of the
cloud to actually create
a full solution for managing
IoT devices or managing data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]